yeah headwind welcome to this video
thing Grandmaster L normal age yo ma ma
oromo is he doing this game classical
stuff he plays the trash quite often
well not anymore this one who you know
that's not one of my strong suits
opening wise cam gambling here if you
place about Vinnie kiss I haven't idea
ok it doesn't five early
Jim make sure how I play ya do AG reform
the minority attacking all da do
97 I guess he wants to do g6 yeah and
then trade off
interesting client 97 86 I have still
managed to get be five in
it should be very slightly better for me
okay there sometimes technical tricks
like this why im looking a little bit
hard looking a little bit here when 95
and then stuff like that but it doesn't
work here 94 94 error there is no
nothing here slightly surprising look
slightly looks a little bit like like
that could be could be a tactic but
there isn't okay 94 takes takes okay
three
shouldn't go into into any more pins
here the black is ok here is quite
active you might be five point isn't
isn't all that great ok night xt5 is
that doing any good takes takes an
e-form probably nothing special you know
nothing special for just the night over
to deform ok
maybe have 94 and I'm counter play
against f2
you
look really not much to do here
I don't I don't see how any really good
idea to make any headway and if King now
is moving up the board to see five
[Music]
yeah I should better just be cook a ham
position is a little bit tricky but it
will become extremely difficult to
defend if I'm taking more time and still
nazism to pick up the beep beep beep on
now for example who gave five cakes as
you see six and there will be six so
it's not not so easy FM look a for
threatens 92 mate second tix tonight
and when she I don't see any thing that
you can do here I'm probably find my
plane is 25 of course and now after f5 i
can even contemplate night on King King
to e5 with this was the original idea ok
for now is a little bit awkward
navigant I wanted to try to do something
so little bit of risk is acceptable with
it okay i guess i can take now i have in
90210 ticket form time morning check
check
group c 6 t king doesn't work
unfortunately
oh man and I completely forgot that he
can push now check check black forfeit
on time did you see that he was so low
yeah okay well position is a draw again
now that wasn't up and down I mean I
think he was very okay here and and and
later but then it shifted in my favor
somehow okay here he appears to he is
totally fine i mean not ft 6 okay now he
should be okay here as well I mean it's
just very active I think that was a good
plan yeah b6 unsurprised middle but I
thought that this weekend's himself but
ok I don't think it's a big deal now you
know feeling I should I should have
something and I have a lot of it takes
place whoopsie to now look C 2 is
putting him into took one actually now
now he has to move the King now and then
i invade its need and here this is this
is really a great time to fly here okay
okay yeah i was better here but ok then
this was wrong but i didn't understand
what am I doing here after this OS 5 of
course I can just take with the king ah
ah let us do yeah
didn't I completely know as two ND did
not understand that I can take with this
this is of course a completely winning
ending okay then who gauge 6 is of
course yeah the engine at 1g six then I
didn't see this and this is why I've I
applied to look down into the center
yeah I think at the end here I can do so
much more precise ok and where you have
to be quick here yeah I think gender
this is a very Jewish position it should
be at all ok guys thanks for watching